i've never done ayahuasca so it's a
mixture of two plants one of them is dmt
but a lot of people i really respect
very very intelligent people
had profound experiences with i o with
ayahuasca what is that what where do you
go where does the mind go what the heck
is up with that
i'll first say that i am like i can't
even smoke weed i really do not enjoy it
uh because i hate to let go of control
like
if i feel out of control in life it's
like one of my biggest weaknesses it's
like very scary for me i don't and and
some people you know really enjoy
letting go in that way
i really don't
so i was pretty terrified to make the
jump then to ayahuasca
but
my wife who i deeply respect
um
made a profound change through ayahuasca
and i saw it she led the way yeah and it
wasn't a strange like i think most we
have a thing
in america that's very like a
misconception a stigma on
psychedelics where
you know it's like it's a drug
and it makes some people crazy and then
you're gonna be on the street you're
gonna be out of your mind or you're
gonna become like
you know
a crazy person basically and i think i
really bought into that notion because
again i was raised i wasn't even raised
with cable tv you know what i mean like
ayahuasca is very
i didn't you know you can imagine what
that was like for a mormon kid i didn't
know anything about it and never touched
drugs at all and never even touched a
cigarette you know
um
anyway so i think we have this
misconception about it
where americans are quick to go to their
doctor and take
any medication
or drug
um but you know
whoa when it comes to like
psychedelics
anyway
that being said i so i had that
trepidation going into it but i really
love and respect my wife and i saw it
make a profound impact in her life where
she suddenly was
able to
heal from a lot of trauma that she had
she had a really
she went through a lot in her life
and it really helped her heal but it
also set her in a new path spiritually
that seemed
really
like a place that i wanted to be
so i did it
and i did it twice the first time it
didn't really have an effect on me which
happens to a lot of people i guess
i drank you know this little thing and
there was like this shaman who came over
from overseas that was really
had been in in the plant you know world
for
decades and was a really incredible
um i don't even know if he likes to be
called shaman um but
they're supposed to be like 30 60
minutes to take effect and a few hours
uh the the the journey lasts about four
or four hours four hours
yeah so the second time i took it i took
took it in i would say 20 30 minutes in
exactly i started to
i started to feel like
i was like the dimension of what is
reality the curtain was pulled open
and
there was a lot more
to
discover
and it really blew my mind in a way that
i think it would probably blow anybody's
mind if for instance god descended or
some christian god or whatever it is we
all think it'd be this beautiful thing
but in reality it would probably make
people super fearful and think that
they've lost their mind
um like i've always yeah
i've always liked joked that if the
mormon god came down and told my mom
like
if god himself came down and told my mom
mormonism is incorrect she would say
satan yeah you know
we're never i think our minds are just
not prepared for a lot of of uh
of anything that's really extreme and it
was very extreme it was like the curtain
of life was was cut open
which scared me but then i felt very
much and a lot of people that i talked
to have a similar thing where i felt
very much like i was either
communicating with
something that was perceived as
god to me or highest sense of self or
mind
or mother earth or you know it's called
so many different names but it's really
it's very
a lot of people have a very spiritual
similar experience with ayahuasca
and just in that it's like this kind of
profoundness it wasn't like
there was nothing uh at least for me
that was
um that felt like just like much like
psychedelic funny cartoons or something
it was like i'm about to go on a journey
and it's and i'm gonna communicate i'm
communicating with something that feels
incredibly wise
showed me a lot of things in my life
kind of almost like from a bird's eye
almost like i was looking through a
video camera a younger me
there was a particular thing that it
communicated to me
um
i really have a hard time with with
accepting success and not feeling um
like feeling undeserving or something i
can't quite put it into words but
of of my position and what i've been
given i've been given so much um
and it showed me this thing from when i
was young and explained to me why i am
where i am now and and i i to this day
like
it did not feel like myself telling
myself that that's the only way i can
explain it like and there was a lot more
that it showed me and and that was
incredibly healing for me
but just in to be
like
to put it into a short
thing because there's so much to this
it felt i walked away feeling very
convinced that
there is more to be known for sure
and
a lot of my deep like things that were
traumatic for me
didn't feel traumatic anymore
specifically crisis of faith i was very
angry at my parents
and
my community for raising me in what i
perceive to be
falsehoods
um
and that and and that uh
i felt like the bedrock of everything i
believed was ripped out for me in my 20s
and then it was like good luck in life
but really my parents had given me
everything that they could and they
believed that very much so still
but a naive young me was angry and felt
like
they had been duped and thus i had been
duped
but ayahuasca
really showed me this road map of like
this is truth and you're concerning
yourself about a grain of sand which is
mormonism or whatever it is
and there may be some truths in that
tiny grain of sand and there may be
falsities
but so is all these other grains of sand
like focus on the truth stop focusing on
these little details that are
meaningless and forgive and let go of
people believing in those things to
begin with
i don't know if that makes sense but
that was like the core thing i was
taught and to let go of control
stop needing to control everything and
it felt like the wisdom was coming from
elsewhere like really i
do not believe at least in my current
self i don't have that
the the mindfulness
that i believe that exists in me to to
reach a lot of the conclusions that i
did and there was a lot more to it
that would be for like a late night
conversation with you but
it's so hard to put it into
you feel like a crazy person any at
least anytime i talk about ayahuasca to
someone who hasn't done it i'm like i
don't even know where to begin like
how do you explain to someone that you
felt like that
a multiple dimension
type thing happened in a way that like
putting it into words is and none of it
was words by the way that was
communicated to me it was like
you know people talk about um telepathy
and if it if it existed it would be like
i could communicate to you in such a
deeper way i'm so confined by me having
to articulate these words and put them
in a sentence to you lex and then tell
you like if only i could just be like
yeah and emotions do that sometimes
right you could see my emotions and be
like
oh that communicates a lot so that's
what it felt like to me with ayahuasca
as it felt like
it was communicating to me very clear
things but it wasn't like daniel it's me
yeah mother earth yeah let me let me
relax sit back let me show you but
but it very was very clear to me what
was being said and no it did not feel
like me uh but
maybe science smarter people than me
who've done it would say well it was you
and blah blah blah like i don't know but
yeah they're very convincing there's a
lot of stuff in that subconscious that
we haven't explored like we haven't
explored the depths of the ocean we
haven't really figured out what's that
the younging shadow what's going on
underneath the surface of our conscious
mind right and what is that connecting
to is that is that just inside our mind
or is it some kind of is there some kind
of collective intelligence going on
where all humans are connected to one
kind of
uh greater
organism like what is consciousness
we have a lot of hubris in thinking we
understand
any of it like how the mind works yeah
at all like what is it
uh like
where
what is the origin of consciousness
what is the origin of intelligence
there's a lot of hubris about this we we
give each other phds and nobel prizes
and congratulate ourselves as if we
figured it all out
um but humility is helpful here
nevertheless that is the question that
humans have been asking for
um
ever since
humans were humans
which is the question of mortality the
question of god
you